you might imagine that faced with a
large defeat in the 2020 election
donald trump's press secretary and
senior campaign advisor kaylee mckennany
would be quietly preparing to ride off
into the sunset to some media gig to
some consulting gig
somewhere joe biden is likely going to
end up with 306 electoral votes just
like donald trump had in 2016
but unlike donald trump who lost the
popular vote by 3 million
joe biden is on track to win the popular
vote by five
5.5 maybe even six million votes
when all of the counting is done but
it's not stopping kaylee mckennany
she will not stop humiliating herself
and we're going to look at some clips
today
i'm wondering maybe whether there's a
long game that she's playing here like
maybe kaylee
has the sense or she's been told if you
can keep this up
uh at some point in his next endeavor
donald trump is going to give you a
really cushy gig
because quite frankly i don't know how
else we can understand
why she's behaving in this way maybe i'm
trying to apply logic where there is no
logic let's see what you think after you
see these clips
so to start with last night donald trump
and many republicans
were hopeful that wayne county in
michigan was not going to certify their
election results just that one county
uh and because the trump campaign has
had no victories
so far speaking you know legal victories
they were starting to say wow wayne
county won't certify
we won here is kaylee mckennany cheering
it with sean hannity last night
wayne county canvassers say we cannot
certify this election because
of these witnesses they're real people
and one reporter tweeted out this is the
first time
in my 20-year history i've ever seen
something like this a county commission
refused to certify
it's because for the first time you have
a president for fighting for the
forgotten men and women in detroit
in philadelphia and democrat cities
across the nation now
unfortunately for her these claims about
wayne county
were bogus and within minutes of kaylee
saying this to sean hannity wayne county
did certify the election as they should
have
and michigan is now uh a closed book
essentially
then we go from talking about michigan
to talking about pennsylvania
as you may have heard rudy giuliani
yesterday
went over the line from just being
donald trump's tv lawyer to actually
arguing before a court uh it reportedly
was
a huge embarrassment but here is sean
hannity saying i heard rudy was
brilliant in court yesterday
all right in pennsylvania rudy giuliani
argued the case today
i've heard from more than a few people
that he was absolutely brilliant
in his arguments today what's the status
of that so the idea of rudy being
brilliant in court at this point is
hilarious and we later heard that rudy
made no sense at all in court yesterday
at one point rudy giuliani apparently
raised the idea that some kind of
mafia-like organization
stole the election for joe biden in
court rudy giuliani brought this up
and it was reportedly a legal
embarrassment for giuliani
let's continue here is kaylee mckennany
holding up papers again it's almost a
requirement now if you go on tv to argue
that joe biden stole the election
you have to hold up affidavits and sean
hannity mentions this
and says kaylee show them how the pages
aren't really blank like some people
said
these papers these affidavits 234
pages of sworn affidavits under penalty
of
perjury by the way county
what did cnn say about when you held
them up on this program didn't they
accuse you of holding up blank sheets
that's right they did about a 10 minute
monologue saying these were blank
they're not blank in fact these pages of
paper
from one county were the reason that you
had a county
level wayne county canvasser say we
cannot certify this election because
of these witnesses they're real people
now
of course they did certify and the issue
isn't whether the pages are blank
it's that the stuff on the pages is
absolute and complete nonsense so that
was last night
i think um that last night she was
senior campaign advisor on the sean
hannity program
now this morning kaylee went back on fox
news this time on fox and friends
and today she was no longer trump
campaign senior advisor today
she was white house press secretary and
host brian kilmeade
clarifies that this is a game they play
thanks so much griff meanwhile let's
bring in kaylee mcandy she's functioning
with us today as the white house press
secretary
so today she's white house press
secretary on fox news remember last week
on fox and friends she was not white
house press secretary last week on fox
and friends she was trump campaign
senior advisor
so when they asked her questions about
what does trump believe about this or
that last week
she said oh that really would be a
question for the white house
which of course she is the spokesperson
for the white house but last week she
was not appearing in that capacity
um the question here it's completely
kafkaesque
is the way i would describe it here uh
kaylee was asked about donald trump
cancelling his thanksgiving trip
to his resort in florida um and kaylee
frames it as
he's hard at work now the truth is trump
is in a bunker mentality
he's not being seen in public maybe
he'll take questions today
we've not seen him take questions for
weeks at this point in time
but kaylee says he's just so hard at
work he's going to stay at the white
house
so kaylee we know the president and
melania the first lady are going to
celebrate thanksgiving there at the
white house and
normally they go down to mar-a-lago i
know they're going to pardon the turkeys
why they decide to stay in d.c this year
well the president's hard at work he's
hard at work on covet among other issues
drawing down our number of troops in
afghanistan and iraq bringing our men
and women home
um he's hard at work um and so he's
staying here at the white house and it
will be a lovely thanksgiving for him
and the first lady
i'm here in the white house all right do
you think we'll hear from the president
soon
uh perhaps that's up to president trump
um you know sometimes he'll make the
decision to come
out on any given moment but i'm sure
you'll hear from him at the right moment
now donald trump has not been hard at
work when you look at donald trump's
schedule this week
you see that he has had nothing on his
schedule other than golf
and lunch with mike pence and it's been
weeks since he's taken
any questions from the media just a
couple more clips
here kaylee dismisses the public health
guidelines
about slowing the spread of coronavirus
as orwellian
when they bring up at fox and friends
the fact that we have
cartoonishly high numbers of coronavirus
cases
but we know all across the country
kaylee cases
are spiking unfortunately and this is
the week
before thanksgiving when families are
going to be together
and there are a number of governors who
are suggesting look
you don't need to be in a in a big group
particularly if people are outside your
bubble
what do you think of these suggestions
and guidelines some of the governors
have given
in advance of this because it is a super
contagious disease
yeah i think a lot of the guidelines
you're seeing are orwellian
um let me start by saying the cdc has
put out considerations
as we prepare to go about thanksgiving
about socially distancing wearing masks
doing what you can
there's a whole list a page of very good
considerations and in that they say
we're not recommending a certain number
of people but we are giving
considerations that you should
put in place it's orwellian now to do
what every
sensible country is doing that's really
something and then here kaylee mckenna
he continues talking about a second
trump administration
as if we're just weeks from donald trump
being sworn into a second term
uh a stockpile that was left empty by
obama biden that he's filled up
since then he's left an infrastructure
in place
where covid can be handled um and we
believe that uh we will do so going
forward in a second trump administration
all right okay i mean yeah there's not
much else to say about that
and then lastly of course white house
press secretary kelly mckennony will not
commit to a peaceful transfer of power
if the president doesn't win and joe
biden is
it's proven that he is the elected
president what happens with the transfer
of power
will it be peaceful look this president
has always said um
he will engage in a peaceful transfer of
power if the facts bear out that way but
the president
believes and so too uh do many others
that if every legal vote is counted
he will remain president he's pursuing
litigation but this president always
wants what's in the best interest of our
country
so day after day another embarrassment
another humiliation and i do hope that
once
joe biden selects a press secretary for
his administration
the relationship between press secretary
and and the country will normalize
it's been hysterical and histrionic
during the trump administration it was
that way with sean spicer
was there somebody there was somebody in
between oh sarah huckabee sanders
how could i forget um and now with
kaylee mckenna
it's been absolutely ridiculous and
hopefully we'll see something a little
bit more normal
during the joe biden administration
follow us
on instagram for more on this and
other stories i'm on instagram
david.pacman
and you can also follow the show at
david pakman show
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video